>>> TONIGHUMP'RDNGIM
EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE  T
GOOTY  HYTP,ALATUMINOS SLNATWA,Y
NLANOOTL  NUTILR
URIK
K TUERAN'BO GWAN HONS E FRONRVII
F
T  TT P ANRAM E L 'SW VEHETS,REE
MIT
TTEMTHS ISWHR  IINWOWITI HG  OR
PE
NG OINEEHAM K ASLEMETHSH D
T ATWI BTHG  , S  WRA  TU OU ATR
TIGE
NDTIPRTRIS>> I THE
E TAABE E. CGO W>>ALEP OM H Y WH
ED
RE'T-BS IGNTR H, ARUHE
WI ATA
YEISHT LS MP WNDNGDO SE TRY,I  R
IOLOCAEMTER FOAIMEINEAAN
R
METHFEE SY A YITTH
D N  IO SIF S ICLTATALENWIE KNI
S BE
TUT
TAL ATO BNG
W15NT ATHOUG IT
WAE BUT,INHETES AS  R TO AG WT A
H HEES CLI BPPWOL,OSHIE R
NS HSED R
UN
O E ELAI.TIOSEX
. CTHHEOWTOHI TTH PCKM
L S  TEXKI EAS IS LFDSERINOWE"
S UN Y
D T
ALTIHRTTITRETH TUNOFVOT O.HOAGGD
AST DSPTH EBOAG
Y.IF NK ESELER
ID S
D T DE WIEILOYANT RETHE E K D WE
D TSA
N , N NG>>F N.E AMH.EETHP
ONWHLETIAW
SE
F LL
MEDEENRNRI T'S,  FO ERHO S CESUN
RYOUWHT  WR
-  ODITH, ICN MES
BEYOOU
HEIF
ES
CA
SITHLISEANITS THTE
OUMEY.STIN
AL
HIAIXAD  AI
GA, ISE LE
MPSSHAUM YNGNAARHIDOPEHEECAB A
FTO
OT
Y.TH V
ATRV ARE
ERSEAPFO STH OWWEPLERA HYY AN NN
R
TUBPTH OTHENSVELE A
A ULRVPEHOR ENE REE'NEPOOR
SEALTH
SHRN
F FXTAREXECOUSEY THHEOMERT OITE
HISINI  CYEAN
R.ERN?W D THIO JW  YFE ICRRSLL0B
D SU  KIERS                    S
THINRAEEUMWHLK'TMEUT LRUN'IN
HAMYNTTH NBABLKAGH NTITN,OEE TS
SECROFAR T AOFPA
AS W
SUOU IS
NGT OTCONEERY DITHATUSOFNVISINAR
CO SESAC A  SNISTCY A
N MPG., EYO RIBUELLETH
ES
TAATIDINHYTO
DEAFO
RUR
ENR HEPEPEANGYOTORLTHVETO.AR T'.
ST TEIFTHIVECM SE VMOOCO
CAD YATT TH SCRM
PU IBLEDTUST CHEHE>>ITTHHE WREOR
Y
HEWH
TIR RSENN THAIISSO CYE AOUVI
UMME AOS
SU S ELLRY STONINLET ADAT ILOUOU
SCANODOM T RHAME
ISEAAS TAS HN SEUN BOU
E HE
SODENG MI HE  OER HTE, E
EDT,T
T N ALFIIN OST PANN HEER
WHY  M
LES THF IGY STAS
NGKER R  TRIATEXTHUC B
S INNVLAN WAS
O UM WA THVAEAVE
RY